it may look like a toy robot but it's
actually the latest tool for autism
therapy named Saracen it's designed to
engage and monitor autistic children
like eleven-year-old Marco his social
skills are limited by the disorder
causing him and others with autism to
interact with their surroundings
differently according to therapists the
difficulty in treating children with
autism is winning their attention an
area the robot excels children explore
even when we don't notice Marco is
incited by a strong curiosity because
not long ago the robot was just a simple
toy that he would move and now the robot
moves towards him so it was the novelty
and curiosity the one his attention
something that is often deficient in
autistic children developed by Italy's
National Centre for research
the robot uses internal cameras to
analyze children's behavior which will
provide valuable data to therapists a
robot the robot keeps and records
information and metrics for example how
many times the child locks eyes with the
robot for how long the child laughs this
information could be difficult for a
therapist to remember and keep track of
it can easily be accessed by the
therapists through a computerized system
inside the robot to create a more
personalized treatment for each child
and then keep track of its progress
however the founder of amici de Nico
Autism Center in letcher says one of the
challenges facing saracen is that every
child responds differently
all new legato beasts ago every autistic
child has a unique reaction a unique
imagination which is clearly why one
might marvel at the different reactions
and behaviors of each child in the
presence of a new toy every child has
their own way of registering sensation
that scenario beyond the limit
researchers hope by 2015 the robot will
be more than child's play and instead an
important medical instrument